uh thanks everybody for showing up uh
it's it's a pleasure to have Anthony
Chen
um here from Caltech
um he's a PhD student working with
Fernando brandow and Joel trop
um in math and physics
um
and he he works at this intersection of
quantum information Theory and Quantum
Dynamics
so
um using tools from Matrix concentration
thermodynamics and Quantum algorithms so
I think this should be a very
interesting talk so uh Anthony looking
forward to it
well thanks for a nice introduction so I
guess I should just begin
um
um today I'll be talking about the
reason work about a Quantum algorithm
that
will prepare is the thermostat of your
common system
this talk is based on a few works that
one is being currently updated the other
one will come out very soon so we might
just wait a little bit
um and let's get started
when I saw the task we're considering
today is to sample Gib sticks however
precisely you're given a quanta
hamiltonian
also like content computer
and the goal is to prepare the thermal
state
the thermostat is the object can you can
take from the physics textbook
it's also called a Gibb State it's a
density Matrix which is diagonal on the
energy basis
and these energy states are weighted by
disbursement Factor exponential minus
beta e or is it is the energy
if you make beta equal to zero this
weight is you know is the maximally
mixed state if you make beta very large
and then this is the ground state okay
so you want to go to the lower energy
state
and that's our goal
um and let me motivate this task by a
very practical usage of common computer
which is on a simulation it's currently
a very popular candidate for practical
quantum speedups
um to very quickly review the goal of
corner simulation is to mimic the
properties of physical systems using a
Chrono computer the question you can ask
are including sacral energy or some
Dynamic properties of your material or
some chemicals
um people have identify the following
keys of routines that you need to do
um in order to successfully simulate
your material
and among these the most mysterious one
is the preparation of the initial state
and so indeed if you look at some of
these proposals by companies that try to
get a a complete resource estimate of
such a quantum chemistry or material
simulation task there is a very very big
mystery of how expensive it is to
prepare
an appropriate initial state
if the number is a million then it could
really impact whether on computers are
really useful
so it turns out this mystery of low
energy states is therefore very good
reasons we can get very different answer
depends on who you ask
from a complexity Theory point this
problem feels very hard in the worst
case so indeed um in the worst case this
is qma heart is some kind of version of
content of content MP heart that we
don't even expect from a computer to
solve efficiently
that seems to be a bad news
um however if you ask physicists when
they would tell you is that you believe
in thermodynamics
so if you just put your system into a
fridge as physicists have been doing
every day in their lab
um
um thermodynamics tells you it is
naturally in their lowest energy states
or the thermal State just depends on the
temperature
they see a big difference between this
worst case and suppose the average case
behavior that we see in daily life and
it really boils down to which assumption
that you want to use to make this
distinction
there's even another angle that if
you're just using classical computers
um there even exist very um empirically
very efficient heuristic classical
algorithm that could sometimes solve
this problem
so you now already see there's a wide
range of landscape of what could happen
in terms of low energy states
and in particular if you want to argue
that quantum computer can do very well
um then you kind of want something in
the middle but maybe it's comfortably
easy but classical
so this has been a very active direction
that many people are working on
um and and the thing we want to do here
is really to draw the right assumptions
and algorithm that allows us to cut
these different regimes
okay
but as a motivation and our goal for
today is to provide a new angle on these
State preparation Problem by proposing a
so-called Monte Carlo style Quantum
algorithms
okay what do we mean by that
um it is a very close cousin of
classical Monte Carlo methods or
classical Gibbs sampling
um
so classical morning Cloud what you do
is is usually use it on initially for
physics simulation of icing models but
later on has take up and have wide
application is also a problem you can
think about okay the spirit here is that
there's an algorithm it's easy to use
um there are not too many parameters to
tune and then someone give you a problem
you can just run it and see how good it
works
and I want to make
um analogy that the algorithm would
propose for today is the Quantum analog
that also have this robust and Universal
feature that you can just look at a
chronohammad alien and throw it to it
and see how it works maybe it works
maybe it doesn't work so well but you
can always try
um
um at the same time also want to draw a
connection to physics
um and in fact the algorithm we propose
are
um deeply rooted in physics especially
thermodynamics okay and the Dynamics
when your system is interact in an open
system uh with a thermal valve
um therefore understanding our algorithm
also leads to understanding and physics
of these various uh recent uh fields of
recent interest
um
um and so that's what uh roughly be a
picture we're having today
right and let's begin our talk
um we've been reviewing the classical
Minecraft chain Monte Carlo methods
the spirit there is that you want to
implement a markup chain
that converts to a dipstick
if you look at this simple example it's
a random walk a line there are four
energy States from zero to three
and you can calculate that the keep
state is going to be some exponential
decaying function with no service split
at the lowest Energies
which is zero
okay so you can convince yourself that
if you want this markup chain to go to
the serial then these arrows should have
a stronger bias toward the lower energy
states
however more precisely if you want the
stationary distribution to be the Gibb
State and then you have to choose on
this transition weight a little more
carefully
and a very powerful and very general
recipe is called detailed balance
so what we're going to do is to impose
that
at the stationary state
the flow forward and backward cancel out
each other
okay so this the equation I wrote down
here
and then you can just invert this
equation and and check that indeed
um the above number satisfies this
condition
therefore on this Markov chain above
indeed converts to the Gibson
and since this problem is so simple you
can also calculate how fast this makes
so just want the random number
however the power of marketing only
parallel is that it works Beyond this
very simple almost contrived example
okay so now the key is that um how do
you impose this detailed balance for
more General and very complex markup
chain
for this um let's look at the
representation of the transition Matrix
okay so let's now sort
um the configurations by their energies
you want on YouTube
and then detailed balance in this
picture is some kind of symmetry of this
Matrix
um it has to obey this particular rule
of that if you just flip across the
diagonal then these two are related by
this number
and this number depends only on the
energy difference
well this looks kind of delicate because
the Symmetry that if you fix the above
triangle then the lower triangle is also
fixed since very delicate
however there's a very robust and almost
a blind way of imposing detailed balance
it's really the Insight of marketing
column method is that you can do this
without knowing the entire Matrix you
can do this quote-unquote locally
so what you're trying to do is to start
with a symmetric markup chain and then
you're going to sometimes reject one One
Direction of the move
once you do that you penalize one of
these transitions which is in color red
and then you end up getting this
detailed balance condition and you can
tune
um the the temperature parameter beta
this turns out extremely powerful
extremely robust you can do it in many
many cases
and most notably um this came from the
Metropolis Hasting algorithm that's
still being applied today
to get a very concrete feel here's the
input to your algorithm
as a user you only need to specify the
hamiltonian temperature and the setup
jobs and you need these jumps so that it
could Traverse the landscape of the
hamiltonian
um for a country examples consider icing
model on some some spins the spins could
be up or down plus or minus ones and you
can specify some pretty arbitrary
coefficients this is JHS but you put
that in your computer
and then now you specify the jumps
um and quite often you can take this to
be local flips a more fancy Choice also
works but it's a very iconic example
so here's a schematic picture of the
algorithm now you can start with some
pretty generic initial state that you
can efficiently prepare and then you
start iterate the following markup chain
you randomly flip one of the this spins
that's your jump
and then you check that whether the
energy has decreased or increased let's
go to what could happen
and if it decrees that's good news let's
accept and keep moving
if it increased that's bad and sometimes
you have to reject this move to ensure
detail balances
and here if I reject I mean that you
would just undo the jump
and then and then do the whole thing
again
so now this is remarkable chain and if
you get this is a well-defined algorithm
you can just wait for this error to
converge you might not always know how
fast the conversibly can you always try
and then if it actually converts um this
would be the give state
that that your output is going to be a
sample from dipstick
all right so that's a classical Monte
Carlo
um the reason why I'm plotting this up
is just
we will this is a really use what we
want to do but try to push it in the
quantum in a Quantum case so here's a
list of things that you want to
generalize
you want to generalize spin
configuration to entangled Quantum
States
um you want instead of a classical
distribution of Gibb States you want to
um have an incoherent mixture of
of this keeps weights on the energy
basis
could be non-commuting
okay so these energies they could be
pointing at pretty generic directions it
could be very entangled
and Elder jumps instead of spin flips
now you can do all kinds of local poly
rotations okay also choose more fancy
choices but this is enough
and now the challenge is how do you
design an algorithm in the spirit of
Monte Carlo that is also widely
applicable and easy to use
um that has similar properties
so far there seems to be lacking a
satisfactory algorithm with the
guarantee that has detail balance and a
correct fixed point
and that led along the discussion of
mixing time
um without defining a search or not
okay so today we're going to fill in
this blank on the on the corner online
we'll discuss it separately in two parts
uh one question Anthony sorry uh yeah so
when you send when you said this part
one and part two is missing uh do you
mean local flips are missing in the
quantum world because there is a Davis
generator in all right
right so I say they're unsatisfactory so
there are lots of proposals but they're
each of them has their own issues okay
okay thanks
thanks
um
now let's dive into the first part of
how you go about designing such an
algorithm
so um people have been trying this for a
long time
um so one thing you can do is is to is
to is is to do that oh maybe I can just
do a trap list on an energy basis
that's a reasonable try uh and all that
you're doing is to replace the spin
configuration with each individual
energy against it
and this could kind of work formally we
just replace Z by the projectors and
then you replace this transition by the
amplitudes right so the right hand side
is this natural Quantum
um transition rates it's now it's some
amplitudes between two states and the
operator and this job operative
so in in this picture uh if you want to
look at this transition Matrix
that's sorted by energy
um
um it would suggest that you want to
look at this band of that of the same
energy transition energy difference
Omega
this is like a classical analog
so this seems somewhat reasonable
um however the hair has been severe
challenges that's intrinsic uh to
quantum mechanics
what are they so algorithmically
um the rejection step turns out being
quite delicate
basically you can easily reject a move
um just by cloning the previous state
or you can unjump and go back to the
previous stage you can do this many ways
the quantly um you can measure the state
the better that I Collapse the state and
you also cannot clone a state
so that is becomes a little more I have
to do this more carefully you have to
pick up some algorithm that does this
job
um
um to some of you you might have
recognized what this algorithm is doing
area launchers
and the problem inside if you want to do
this algorithm I also that this problem
becomes very convoluted once you
consider the challenges below
these challenges are that
fundamentally energy measurements is
uncertain
it's very difficult to make very precise
energy measurements usually that invoke
an exponential cost
and that brings lots of issues
so most importantly detailed balance is
broken
so if you have worked with smarter chain
we really really love detailed bands
there are so many nice properties
um and now lift detail band is broken
how do you even know the fixed point is
the correct one
and second that's more of the Second
Step
um issue is how do you think about
mixing in these contexts
it seems that it has to be intrinsically
Quantum because now nearby energy could
just stay entangled and move around
because your energy measurements does
not distinguate this entangle the nearby
energy states
and there are lots of attempts
to address these challenges
so now let's take a step back
um that well how come there are so many
obstacles but nature film lies so nicely
how come there's this empirical success
of thermodynamics
right if you ask experimentalists they
would just put their device into a
fridge and lower the temperature of the
fridge then you get ground state or
thermal States
it's very robust pretty Universal you
just do it
um
so it turns out this nature really knows
how to do it and our algorithm is
heavily inspired by Nature
um so let's see what what this nature
can give us the first observation
um this is proposed by 50 years ago was
by Davis is that if you use a continuous
walk since nature is continuous
then this rejection step is
automatically resolved you don't have to
do anything fancy
so the picture is that um
um this content
um process now continues so then if an
essentially um you always
um
get these transitions
right and and now you can take these
transitions to be your Fitness favorite
amplitudes of a sandwich between energy
states the ones that we have been
talking about
and now instead of doing rejection step
all you do is to simply lower the rate
of The Unwanted transitions
so you really just multiply
this infinite as small transitions by
the appropriate weights
in particular you can choose this way to
satisfy detailed balance and that
guarantees the fixed Point as gifts
yep so the point in this slide is that
if you have continuous time some of
things are better you don't have to
worry about rejecting this rejection
step in discrete Metropolis
and of course this doesn't solve every
problem this was a 50 year old proposal
and there they make a very strong
assumption that essentially you can
measure energy very precise so then you
can really refer to the precise energy
Omega
this very precise band of transitions
on this picture
so we still have work to do but this
ends up serving as the essential
intuition that these two algorithms
to give it a little bit of more of a
context on these so-called continuous
time random walk in the quantum world
are called in the audience
um it takes this one this general form
okay this is what it is
um you can choose various kind of
operator K that would drive the
transitions the infinite and SML Quantum
transitions of your system
and what you get in the end
um when you act is in the login on a
Quantum State
um it's a continuous family of markup of
of States that's parametrized by
exponential LT
and it's different from unitary Dynamics
as these Maps could have a fixed point
that just shrink every implicit state to
one fixed point
so that's possible
okay um and for those of you who are
more familiar with Quantum channels this
is really the continuous versions and
you can see this cross operator looks
kind of similar but now it has a second
now we're ready to describe a proposal
of ours
um
um now we propose a multicult style
Quantum algorithm in the format
that is continuous Quantum random logs
we're able to efficiently Implement
alien platin whose fixed point is
approximately the gift state
in other words this is in very same
Spirit as Monte Carlo that is very
Universal you can just plug in a
hamiltonian
and then you can run it you could have
different all kinds of mixing time
sometimes it works sometimes it fails
whenever it works you sell it
and it's also very nice that there's
almost no fine-tuning required there's a
very different from variational
algorithms but here there's not that
many parameters you can tune you just
choose the jumps and often this doesn't
quite change the behavior by too much
like if it uses some generic choice
suffices for example local poly flips
further we believe how many results
um of is the right way
um because our formalism directly
generalized to many other settings it
our formalism is compatible with
secretary type speedup that you can
quantize or leaning blood in uh to
obtain
purify version you get some kind of
quadratic speed up
um and that which prepares the purified
give state
also for physics our argument applies to
many physical developing blood units so
we can just look at some audience this
is derived in your paper and and say
that hey this guy actually had the
correct fix point
so just to clarify uh the input to your
algorithm is in blood in and then you
are able to implement that on a quantum
computer is that the message here
uh the input is the hamiltonian
oh I see okay got it yeah
you have algorithm that depends on very
simple very few simple things
so that's the next slide
all right so now now let's look at look
at our main result
as a user
you just choose the hamiltonian
temperature and some set of jumps for
example local police
that defines you ellenbladian
um has its following nice properties
the fixed point is correct up to some
controllable error episode
the algorithm is efficient as long as it
mixes quickly
so in general we don't know what what
what this mixing time is uh it largely
depends on the system but heuristically
you might guess that if things formalize
nice in nature then maybe this mixing
time is not going to be crazy
okay but there will be a another subject
of study
the message here is that this really is
a version of quantum uh on the versions
of Monte Carlo
yeah right fixed point and then you have
some guarantee as long as mixing time is
not crazy
and you can always run it
any more questions
all right so now let's talk about how we
get to our results and here's the secret
sauce
um they make everything work
um the key object that we identify is
this Fourier transform of operator
evolution
okay so it's these things on the top
right
and this a Omega
so let's look at this very carefully
so first is a of t as defined as the
Heisenberg evolution
this is something that you can you found
in physics textbook it's very natural
natural important mechanics
but it does essentially is to add phases
according to the energy difference
okay so from here you can split this
explicitly see
um that this really diagnosis
um energy differences
mathematically you can think of it as
some version of for your integral that
from this continuous case but now we do
it discreetly and you also put some
weight
so now let's keep and pack this the
secret sauce
so what we're looking at here is really
a boosted for your Transformer because
once you've tuned um to this function f
correctly it acts as certain boosted
phase estimation or boosted for for your
transform
um with a tunable accuracy
so pictorial we if you can do for your
transform perfectly then you can access
these transitions at precisely energy of
Omega
however that's really expensive you
cannot really access Quantum energy
perfectly and what you get here is a
compromise that you will have to have
some uncertainty
and as a user you can tune uncertainty
and there will list two different
accuracy of these energy estimates
so it really is just some now like a
smooth version of these pens with some
uncertainty in your Energies
this object is also very nice that it
has a very very simple circuit
okay all you need to do is to input a
gaussian weight wave function to control
that put your weights on your time
register
and then you just time a register to
control on the operator Revolution and
then do a Fourier transform
and the second way you just give the
service things above
and once you have this this component
um you can you can use all kinds of
tricks to generalize to more complicated
objects such as blogging but this really
is the building block
do Fourier transform in this way
one more nice thing about our
construction is that these Fourier
transform operator has certain exact
symmetry
um this is more technical but however
once you have this exact symmetry
um it somehow sort of um as a as a
stepping stone towards detailed balance
to draw an analogy to a classical case
um there you also need to start with
something that's very nice that's
reversible or symmetric and then you can
do all kinds of way to do rejection to
get detailed events it's very similar
here
um that's somehow in a Quantum case once
you have this exact symmetry
um things becomes very nice and it will
lead to detailed balance that we'll talk
about in the next slide
okay so now um I have told you how I
construct
um earlier audience
um one more thing that we have to do is
to argue that this this has the correct
fixed point
and that requires a notion of
approximate detailed balance that we're
not able to find somewhere else so we
just Define it in display
um it looks complicated it has to deal
with some Norm of super operators
but morality What's Happening Here is
you just want to get a sense of how
non-hermation this is
um
and indeed if you make Delta zero
this recovers detailed balance in some
certain hermit some selfish joiners of
this map with respect to the stationary
distribution
in other words the properties of
detailed balance such as the fixed point
is robust once you use it in this Norm
the error propagates in the following
way that you have the error on in terms
of a fixed Point as roughly the mixing
time times this approximate detail
balance error
intuitively
approximately digital balance is some
kind of error per time
and then once you
um evolve for some time this area could
accumulate but as long as your algorithm
converts quickly
to give you the right answer
and then we can calculate this this
Delta
parameter and for volume bloodings this
is relatively
um beta over the resolution or the time
also the time so in other words um in
other words to make approximate detail
balance
um nearly zero you have to pay
um to have a long Evolution time
all right so that's uh our construction
so I want to pause and take questions
very quickly
before I move on to the next current
so I take it in you know in in the
circuit F of T was Zero was your
gaussian right that was that was the bit
to which you yes you spread the operator
yes and then
and somehow then then you're doing
looking at a Fourier Transformer on the
on the on the time somehow and that's
that's giving you something interesting
so
do you want us can you say a little more
about the intuition there
right so what you're doing here is a
forward Transformer if you put a
different F they give you different have
Toyota because you're basically doing
for your transform on this function f
um if you put in gaussian in the Fourier
domain it's also a gaussian
so it means that it's
um it's nice in both time and energy
that is very concentrated in time so
that you can efficiently implement it
you don't have to worry about it tell
it's highly concentrated in energy
so that the energy is very accurate that
um you're basically pretty confident
that your energy is within this interval
um
precaution is nice
um so um
just uh just quick question is it
correct to uh
I'm just trying to recall this so was
the Davis generator Etc the prior prior
constructions where this construction
without the gaussian rates
is that correct yeah you can say that
however
um so yes you can think of this
generator or all kinds of its variants
as putting the the plane just making F
of T constant right there was there was
energy uncertainty right and there's a
huge energy uncertainty a thing will
just make the scaling much worse but it
still kind of work
um but um
um but historically the Davis General
initially just take t equal to infinite
you just allow yourself to resolve
everything exactly that's why it's not
solving the problem and then to have a
finite time version
um it's not so clear
and in fact so you can so people have
proposed something like this in the
physical way they can't arrive in some
way
but the nice thing is that our entire
algorithm
prove that these construction
satisfy approximate detail values
and prove that these physical
construction also has the correct
thermodynamic properties with the right
fixed point
yeah thanks
and there are some questions in the Q a
one question is does the mixing time
also depend on beta and inverse
temperature
okay so exactly so I have
um sweeped a lot of things into into
this mixing time uh mixing time is a
function of of William guardian and in
this body and depends on so many things
um so yeah it's a hard little object
maybe sometimes you can get analytic
control maybe sometimes use two numerics
because it can it's a well-defined thing
it's a function of building plot
unless it's kind of already unless you
can prove it in some circumstances so
you can always try and see if it works
for the moment do you have like an
estimate of how this mixing time scales
with I don't know beta or system size
for this kind of parameters
a very high question
um
yeah I mean
depends on assumptions like maybe if you
set out a problem correctly on like a
like a spin spin that like a spin
lattices maybe you can try to use some
of the existing philosophy like this
Decap correlation stuff to try to prove
this mixing time uh there's going to be
lots of absence until you'll have
playing around
okay thanks yeah and one related
question if you don't mind uh so uh so
let's say the the limbladian without the
gaussian rates was fast mixing for some
reason
would these changes still keep it fast
mixing or good things totally
widely changed so
as a physicist I would say they're
probably all the same
is not not obvious because you just have
a different map
the expectation is that
when you have these fat cells in for
your space you just incur lots of
um unwanted transitions because
sometimes you get your energy very wrong
and then the fixed point would just be
kind of far away from this fixed point
or the skill error scaling is going to
be worse
um calcium is just really nice that you
you get roughly the energy you want
could I ask uh just a naive question so
if you if you apply this to a classical
spin system what is the classical
algorithm that you recover
um
so if you start with classical input
and then run this
this is probably very similar to like
some like Global Dynamics I believe
um but if you're implicit of
entanglement then we don't know what
happens
thanks yeah
cool
let me now move on to the second part of
a talk we will give certain mixing time
estimates since we're quite curious
about the mixing time
um and here we is this is a quite a
complicated thing as you know this
mixing time even in classical case it's
not easy to estimate and here we rely on
a strong physics assumption it's called
Quantum chaos that I would Define
further and in that case you can get at
least guess a graphs get a grasp of
what's happening in these very
complicated
Quantum markup chains
foreign and in the following will be
very high level even though there's a
proof I basically uh didn't write down
any quantitative statements
um I just want to highlight the idea
so intuitively whenever you write down
this finite time like this
this um this markup chain with energy
uncertainty you should think of it as a
semi-classical revenue
so you try to import as part of
classical intuition when you're from you
have so he's trying to do some random
work on the energies um and our energy
again faces but now you could have some
entanglement between nearby Energies
this entanglement exists
because
um your Quantum will need to say initial
State could have entanglement but also
um that since you cannot distinguish
Energies
these terms can also preserve this
entangle
how these jumps kind of know the energy
because if the energies are far apart so
then it's semi-classical in a sense say
If energy is a far apart it's incoherent
so if energies are nearby it could be
cohered
and what would you apply these jumps
um you can think of moving these
classical
um probabilities around while with the
nearby energies you can rotate the
vector without disturbing it that's
possible
okay so at a very high level
if you want to prove thermalization
essentially you want to understand how
to get rid of these um these coherence
because in the end you want something
that's a mixture
um on an energy basis
you have to break all the entanglements
okay so this doesn't seem easy to prove
um and we're able to argue
um that this is possible in polynomial
time
um assuming a strong assumption from um
from con chaos
so there's going to be lots of physics
parameter flying around so I just drop
all of them
um I just want to get to the intuition
so what is this Quantum chaos assumption
that seems so powerful
um here it is this is um
um proposed 20 30 Years Ago by physicist
it's called icon State thermalization
hypothesis uh there's not quite a
hypothesis it's more of a condition
that it describes something about the
operator
so you take a hamiltonian
and another operator a
and this eth condition
s of the following
okay this condition holds if for all
physical purposes
we can replace the near diagonal band
with typical sample random Matrix
so normally what we're doing is that you
have some very complicated looking
Matrix
and the physicists just say well why not
just treat all of them as relative
samples from random Matrix
hey mathematically this might feel a
little awkward what we really mean by
replaced
um but operationally it just means I'm
going to do the calculation you just
treat these guys as samples of gaussians
and it allows you to do calculations
and in fact lots of physics operations
are done in this way
again the picture is suddenly analytical
to the energy basis and look at these
Transitions and eth tells you that if
you stay near it on the diagonal then
these transitions are basically random
nature business so it's very densely
connected and nearby Energies
okay so don't ask me where this come
from this is proposed by a physicist and
they just do so on numerics it seems to
be the case that seems to obey um
predictions um for random Matrix
hey um today um this we need eph for
many operators because we have many
jumps we can take them for example to be
local police and we just treat the
gaussian cells independent
across different jobs
okay so it turns out this is enough uh
to guarantee a civilization or rapid
mixing of these um
the intuition um from the classical
Markov chain is that basically you're
looking at a very well connected graph
at least nearby
um indeed and if you look at this Matrix
elements given by eth these rij and gij
are basically uniform so so if you have
input State we just spread you out to
all these different energies and it's
just very well densely connected
well then you can look at some Markov
chain textbook to argue that these graph
connects very thermalized very very
quickly
but this is entirely classical
um what you have to deal with in a
Quantum case is the coherence
because you can have very entangled
state
but you want to nevertheless argue that
it converges to a very mixed state
and to do that we have to borrow some
idea called Quantum expander
um this idea was I think was first proof
by Hasting by considering random
unitaries
but you say that well let me construct a
Quantum Channel by summing out a bunch
of random uniters
and then he proved that um this is
indeed a very good expander in a sense
that it has a large spectral Gap second
angle value is very very small if you
apply this channel many times very
quickly spring
to the maximum extent
so chronic expander it just decoheres
for any input state
so it turns out you can do similar
manipulations or I guess you can get
similar consequences if you assume eth
so because there's some part of ethg's
random Matrix if you use that you can
also get very similar um expander
properties
and in the end I give you this equation
that
this map we're dealing with is very
close to the expected the expectation
now you can think of it as some kind of
concentration statement but now you're
talking about concentration in a very
big gigantic map
okay so now let's assume this this is
this is true so now you have proved this
using some some regular Matrix Theory
um it suddenly reduced the problem
drastically
and actually becomes the classical red
level
so very nicely this expected map
is completely decohered
um it really reduced essentially to a
classical random walk on eigen States
and now you can celebrate because you
can open your knockoff chain textbook
and try to analyze the mixing time of
this this object it becomes a 1D random
walk on energy
and yeah and that that will be the proof
so we you completely understand this
classical random walk and then in the
end you relate
um to the semi-classical object which
seems horrible
um by th
and that's the proof
okay so um let's finish the second part
of my talk
um let me quickly summarize today we
give a proposal of Monte Carlo still
Quantum algorithms
a task we want to solve is to prepare
thermal state of contamintonians
and let me just reiterate the main
findings
in the first part we give the moneycloud
cell algorithm in a form of Limp logins
these are continuous Quantum markup
chains with a guarantee that a fixed
point is approximately the Gibb state
you get errors because energies is
uncertain
and we believe this is the right way
approaching it because our results
generalize to many other settings also
leads to proof of thermodynamics it's
also compatible with column of speedups
of course all these monocolor methods
you have to deal with mixing time that
you don't always know
and we give Arguments for mixing time in
a particular case
um of quantum chaos
um that's some kind of hamiltonians not
all hamiltonians are like that but at
least you get a sense of well because
what's possible uh to be proven
um and with that
um think about at the right time let me
just conclude with on some list of
Future Works
thank you
great thanks a lot
thanks Anthony so
um
let's see there's a question from the
audience uh from let me let me just
allow Finn to talk
do you want to go ahead and ask your
question
excuse me
who is hamiltonian
okay maybe we get rid of this
who is Hamilton
okay
um
all right so um
is there any other question
maybe I'll ask the question hello yeah
uh great thanks yeah that's a very nice
talk yeah so uh I I think we uh briefly
talked about this during a visit last
week which is uh yeah the top really has
two parts right and one is the ground
state and the other is the thermostat
and so thermostat absolutely without
balance is a
is important uh you know would you
clarify the importance of the detailed
balance of ground state Corporation
um right so
so right so the question is how
important is detailed balance if you
want just want to find the lowest energy
State yeah
um I don't think it's entirely important
um because these detailed balances you
want you want to keep State and then all
these analysis are kind of with the keep
state in mind
um
and I think a lot of balance actually
improved could improve a lot if you have
Gap ground States
um It's really because that when you
have a gap
um you kind of don't really care the
energy of your system you just need to
know a state is there
and then a lot of these error balance
actually become loose and you can get a
much tighter abdoms if you just want to
make sure your state is fixed at a
ground state
um and
more practically like if you really want
to run it and say I just want to get a
ground state
um and what you can do you can imagine
that you would start increasing beta
and then maybe so this is about like how
you actually find a ground say how you
get from like a very hot state to a low
energy State
um the initially
um
um energy errors doesn't quite matter
because you just want to get a roof kind
of rough gradient in some in some sense
but then energy estimate might become
more and more important then you might
have to like change your algorithms so
that the energy estimates have are
better and indeed in all these processes
beta isn't quite important because you
just want to go go to a ground state as
quick as possible you might even just
set a video to be infinite
um but it really depends on the
landscape of the hamiltonian
yeah so the intuition is that although
as you said like this is how nature gets
to the ground state but possibly we know
that there are possible algorithms that
works faster than applying into the
mind's beta H and uh to get to to solve
eigenated problems maybe uh in the
context of quantum algorithms you can
also algorithmically find some shortcuts
that does a better than Matrix
yeah exactly exactly like um we're
proposing it's just like one of the very
first kind of a quantity methods
classically their methods Beyond Monte
Carlo
um but these are just very robots you
can always try
um and then
um
you can also even just change your
algorithm
um
yeah I agree I think this is very
exciting
please answer the question maybe I
forget something yes I think it's a very
exciting
um
let's see any any other questions well
maybe just one brief comment for this so
sometimes in this classical space you
get the quadratic improvements compared
to like naive Markov chain methods uh
and uh
in VB also that's this kind of secondary
type speedups so at least that quadratic
Improvement is possible uh when when the
mixing time is nice and so that gives
you at least a quality improvement
compared to just like black demolition
uh with the secondary work you get a
qualific speed up and well I don't know
if you want to get beyond that
uh I think a provable speed up is one
thing but just to say classically you're
better eigen solvers than partner so
maybe in the end there are some
participating we were saying but yeah
the the Practical performance may be
required
I had one question so thank you Anthony
for the very nice talk so in in part two
uh you describe this eth condition which
prescribes some Behavior at the level of
individual eigenstates
yeah it seems uh you know kind of well
very strong and you know perhaps
non-physical if they're not gapped so is
there a way of replacing that by some
more analytic condition involving
resolvance or something like that or
functional calculus
uh
I think I think yes because uh
eventually right so
right so so argument is that okay let's
make them very nice
very nice random Matrix is when you do
some calculation in anything give some
good results and if you just Trace back
um what you really need is just some
double moment properties
and especially this expand their
condition like in classical expander you
can construct randomize randomly using a
lot of Randomness to construct expander
but if in the end some people may just
come up with a like a deterministic
construction
and all you need is really this
expanding property and this contact
expander property
so it is at least something you can
check on a computer that if you if you
um just go to an energy basis for some
set of operators
um there would be conditions of eth in a
sense of expander that can be just
checked like by this is diagonizing the
entire Matrix
does it uh yeah thanks yeah and I had
one more question about part one so in
part one is it true that your Sigma T
parameter that depends on time so
actually the lindbladian changes
depending on how long you intend to run
it for and this is somehow related to
this non-normality of some operator that
appears right or non-hermission so some
operator is that essential or is that
some do you think that's an artifact of
the proof like could there be a version
of this which does not which this works
for all time
I'm not sure I think
one of my area might be able to come up
with slower files because it's like
because energy time and symptoms
like it would seem to me that if you
want to get keep say very precisely
it almost it means that you can really
know the energy of individual State
pretty precisely and then it might not
be able to get some black box to work
balance on like how how fast you can
create this but I don't have a written
down proof
my suspicion is that all these things
will have errors
thanks
okay uh so there's a question from the
government um
uh hello
um you haven't mentioned Quantum Monte
Carlo the algorithm people use to study
on classical computers
um can you compare your approach to
to that like uh you know if you were
interested in Quantum Advantage at least
uh uh you know as a new at a numerical
level might compare
you know your Quant your version of
quantum Monte Carlo to to Quantum Monte
Carlo people use on classical computers
yeah I have not run any column Monte
Carlo in classically
I don't know that but uh but our
organism including principle were
antoniously sign problems
yeah because you can really know the
energies of your States
and let's read content
yeah so uh I guess I'm just wondering so
so that in that in that case what would
the like how how much of an advantage
I've heard people talk about in this uh
uh so far today uh you know this
quadratic speed up but you know maybe
there's an exponential speed up in that
case or
I
exponentials love is possible I don't
know how to prove I mean at least it's
not rule out so it's still possible
but then you have to be careful about
how you set up the problems and the
inputs outputs and stuff
all right thanks
um one quick question I don't know so if
not
um so if the hamiltonian is commuting
then in that case you can measure and
it's a pretty quickly
yes estimation and all uh so
in that case do you need this technology
or just uh so so yes or no
um there are existing Davis generator it
makes a lot of sense um that also
implementable uh you can Define them
precisely for the reason you describe
because they're commuting you can fast
forward that basically I see okay so yes
so there are these guys that existed
um and and yes the point we're making
here is that for non-commuting
hamiltonians
something different has to be done and
we do it in this way and it's operating
naturally we like to spread and then you
have to encounter I have confirmed the
problem that you cannot measure the
energy precisely
okay thanks
so what is a good example that the
problem suffers from the sign problem
but it also has a big gap
now that I can think about right now but
because if the problem comes from the
plus frustration over the classical Soul
then the Gap must be very small right
frustration by definition classical it
means you have a lot of low in the
states with a very very similar right so
so you also
um so if you just give me like a really
hard classical combinatorial
optimization problem
I'm not sure if this will I mean okay
and let's call it yourself if you have
problems otherwise yeah it doesn't work
um there's even intuitive reasons and
why that doesn't oh so so sorry uh I
didn't like quite follow if it's if it's
classical then then there's always a gap
right
uh but it comes from frustration in the
sense that they're just about for
competing states with a very close
energies but that their solution looks
very different uh this algorithm I mean
by definition the capital person
with the sign problem
right and which is hard it also has a
big gap so the yeah the sign problem
shouldn't introduce this classical type
of frustration yeah so exactly exactly
and there is something different exactly
so you don't want to be like a classical
spin glass or classical guitar problems
but also
can that be too nice to have classical
computer can solved
so a good example would be great
so one quick question related to what
and what I was asking me for so uh for
committing hamiltonians you say that you
don't need all this machinery and this
would be essentially for non-commuting
hamiltonians but do you have an
intuition of what happens when you have
something that is non-commuting but very
close in some sense to commuting so in
the sense that it's just you know adding
a perturbation to a commuting
hamiltonian or something like that of
course a perturbation that doesn't
commute do you see if your Technique
simplify or if you get some information
of the mixing on the mixing time or
something like that
yeah I think that's
smells to me like these many by
localization problem
um so pertivatively might allow you to
do to get some control at Short times
but a long time the question is that
does the hamiltonian are still localized
some way um like if things are made by
localized it means that
it remains like basically like these
commuting Napoleon's for a very long
time
um
and that seems a little hard to to do um
you might have you can make some
probably some simplifying assumption to
put that picture
um
but it seems that so now if you just
plug in
some integrable hamiltonian like
community hamiltonian and put some tiny
perturbation and then plug in the
algorithm
um
I think the operator still Sprints like
and then this these um this value will
just keep spreading and spreading get
bigger and bigger
great um so maybe
um shall we uh Anthony if you stop
sharing maybe we could go into the panel
okay stop
but what should I do oh you should stop
sharing the slides I just did oh my
goodness okay so okay good you succeed
all right so
so then as the
you know as the video is getting pinned
for the for the panel uh
uh let me just go ahead and introduce
the panelists so
um so for the panelists we have uh you
know uh Angelo Angela uh Cuevas who's
from the University of turmergan
um so she um she works on of course
Quantum information Theory and
um very appropriately on open Quantum
many body systems
um and uh I guess maybe rapid mixing of
lapis hamiltonian so Angela welcome and
we have um uh David Gossett from the
University of Waterloo who works on on
the algorithms Quantum complexity I
guess he and an Iraq anshu who is also
going to be on the panel uh uh did some
really nice work on area laws uh for 2D
systems David also worked on the max max
cut problem and most recently on on this
complexity of the quantum partition
function which is I think probably very
relevant to this
um great to have anurag anshu back here
from Harvard University
um he um he of course works on on
Quantum hamiltonian complexity
you all know about his work on area laws
and on the nlts conjecture recently and
of course he works here before this he
had a you know he he worked extensively
on Quantum information Theory so welcome
on Iraq and then we have a we have
uh you know it was great pleasure to
that Andres agreed at the last minute to
jump onto the panel and uh
um you know from andrash is of course a
quarter of the paper he's from the
Iranian Institute and he's worked you
know extensively on Quantum linear
algebra
on optimization Quantum walks so
so
um
so maybe we can start with having the
panelists talk about you know get their
thoughts about the about this um this
paper maybe start with Angela with you
okay so well first of all I want to to
say thank you very much for the great
talk because I really enjoyed it and I
already knew a little bit about the
second part that you presented but the
first part was really really interesting
to hear about and I'm looking forward to
to reading the paper
and yeah I found it really exciting
because it's what you were mentioning uh
you know in your list of open problems
and also what you were mentioning during
that talk I think it's really
interesting to be able to provide this
kind of talks and this kind of tools
sorry that allowed you to address the
the sampling problem give sampling
problem for the for non-commuting
hamiltonians I think this was a
um I mean for the second part that you
were mentioned in the mixing time like
the tools to prove rapid mixing using
Wiki dth
for also for the same case right from
augmented hamiltonians this was like a
complete Gap that was in the field for
for a while right and I re I find really
interesting the possibility of combining
tools that are already there to proving
mixing times for commuting hamiltonians
with the tools that you have derived
here for non-commuting hamiltonians so
again congratulations and I'm looking
forward to to reading the paper
yeah
um
maybe uh an Iraq did you have
sure yes uh so thanks Anthony for really
really nice talk um
um so
um I was aware of some questions uh some
very nice results which are already
known in the classical world for example
uh uh some this connection between the
key of correlation and mixing time and
so on uh I don't know what's your view
on whether those those questions which
are still open in the quantum world
would they change now with your new
tools uh would you see some progress in
that direction
so that's uh just very curious to hear
your thoughts on that uh also I had a
quick question I thought that okay the
statement of eth that you displayed uh
in your slides
uh I was aware of a different version
which says that uh an eigen state looks
gives like a Gib State locally so when I
read your abstract in the beginning I
thought oh
are you going to talk about that
connection but it's a different kind of
statement so I mean I don't know if you
have any comments on that
um so Anthony did you want to address
whether the whether these two views of
the ethr equivalent or are they yeah so
so for each age um they're different
um and appears that so in the original
proposal it has both parts one part is
the diagonal part which is the one that
people will mostly use
so what's saying in the diagonal is that
also that's basically the energy states
it tells you that
um
energy against States
if you're closing by energy they
basically give the same expectation for
the observables uh it's basically the
diagonal is very smooth
so then it doesn't matter if you take
the gift state which is has some
collection of states or just like one
state
[Music]
um
and that seems to be very helpful for
physicists
um
but at the same time it's not
satisfactory because it doesn't feel
nothing about the
um the octagonal part so it only tells
you like a tiny tiny color like a tiny
list of entries of your Matrix
and I think people just haven't
like
um spend too much time thinking about
what these angles things are doing
um the one we're seeing here says is off
diagonal things this truly connects to
Dynamics
and Dynamics lead to thermalization and
Rapid convergence to the cube State
um
um and
until it actually tells you how to get
there you know like suppose you have
Chrome computer and then you have one
like an energy against State I have no
idea how you get that but yes if you
have that then it probably have many
properties similar to the thermal state
but other part tells you how to get
there see
um so so here's a question
um Let me give let me try to make a
statement and let me know if that's
right or not um so here's a way to
sample from Gib State assuming this
other version of ADH which is take
maximumic State measure the energy if
you get the energy in the right range
then idiots would tell you that well you
know that looks like this anyway
but uh that's not the way of give
sampling that you would want to do is
no no I mean you can almost do the same
thing for classical like if you have
problems because you can just try and at
least have a lot of spin well this
sounds like not great because I'm most
likely you guys end up in the very
thermal like
um you just can it's very unlikely you
can go far in the low energy states
right I see yeah that's right yeah
because the energy distribution actually
have a tell it's a it's a yeah it's a
gaussian distribution plate yeah and
then this tells what you're interested
in
yeah fair enough the question is how to
get there
um um so you need to perform some random
walk that tries to go like sequentially
lower lower energy
um and any things are nice that's nicely
connected you can just keep going down
but just yeah got it okay
um
David do you have any
any thoughts yeah um thanks Anthony for
a wonderful talk uh I I think it's
fascinating
um that there's a kind of developing
framework for proving uh this kind of
Rapid convergence
uh to the Gibbs state in certain cases
and I want you know I I'm looking
forward to the future development of
sort of importing the tools that that
are available uh in the classical
setting like I don't know I mean Anthony
if there's a conductance type bound or
are things along those lines that could
be applied uh to establish rapid
convergence uh for certain uh certain
models of Interest I mean in particular
like you know
and and maybe this this uh also
um
it relates to the questions about
Quantum Monte Carlo I mean so it is the
case that for you know fair for the
ferromagnetic icing model classically
you know there is a classical Markov
chain that converges uh to the to the to
the Gibbs distribution and
um
and you know that that can be
generalized was generalized by bravi to
the transverse field for a magnetic
icing model because it doesn't have a
sign problem and therefore the Gibbs
state has a classical probabilistic
representation when you expand e to the
minus beta H as a you know in Trotter
Suzuki the path integral has a has a
positive representation as a
distribution overpass
and for Problems Without A Sign Pro
without a sign problem you have a
distribution over paths and you can try
to apply the classical Markov chain
Monte Carlo to that distribution over
paths and proof wrap convergence that
way but it seems to me like you know
it would be really amazing if you could
take a fair magnetic model that is not
that that has a sine problem
and and and and and you know use
and and and and use this kind of uh
Quantum Markov chain and establish
convergence so it to me it seems like a
kind of a an area that's right for for
for for for a lot of different
interesting directions that haven't
haven't been explored yet and I I really
appreciate the uh the the kind of
amazing uh fundamental contributions
that that were made in this work
right um thanks thanks David um Andres
do you have any uh any thoughts or
um
[Music]
you know or different way of
understanding parts of this what's your
yeah well thank you for the invitation
on them for the nice talk Anthony
so uh for me this this this uh talk and
and this whole project was uh about
learning a lot of physics I'm coming
from more of a Quantum algorithm side
and so for me it's exploring all these
physical ideas and tools and and I find
it very fascinating
and I think that that that uh questions
like this are very interesting from the
perspective that they are touching parts
that are algorithm difficulties that are
quantum Wireless people work on and then
also physical side of problems where
like really the quantum uh physics side
uh and those kind of questions uh pop up
and and somehow to to to come up with an
algorithm with simulating uh these
Dynamics or or finds a deep State deep
as a gift State quickly kind of needs
both both of these words and I'm
interested to see how ideas start to
propagate and then I I think I mean lots
of these ideas of course important
Computing already like propagated from
one side to the other but I I think
there is still room for that there is
for example these two uh this Quantum
operator Fourier transform now this is
uh one can view it as just phase
estimation and well just Quantum fully
transform or something you can view the
space estimation I mean the circuit is
just that if you if you wish to say but
on the other hand it is it is a
different perspective on these things
and then you start to think about phase
estimation and operator space and that
has different properties and and if you
understand that way of looking at this
that can give you new insights and I am
curious to see if if this new way of
looking at this this uh these
subroutines will lead to other organic
improvements elsewhere so why I'm really
fascinated by by this kind of
interconnection between this this like
two sides of quantum Computing and I
think we can gain a lot by by connecting
more of these questions so actually I
was I was curious um you know the this
um you know this operator for a
transform that you mentioned so were you
able to get a you know get a different
view of it and you know from a more
algorithmic computational Viewpoint is
it or is that thread still
you know he's still pulling on that
thread and
uh
well I mean one one way of looking at it
is is is just a little bit like um
you you can just vectorize that Matrix
and think about as a Fourier transform
of this vectorized object but then the
interesting thing is that what you get
out of it is still an operator it's not
a state and and so there are certain
things that may be impossible if you are
working with States then then you have
some obstructions that maybe are not
present when you are working with
operators that are just just some action
on Quantum States uh so maybe this is
like one way how the circumstances some
differences but I guess uh I mean
there's still we could actually
understand it better I guess
okay great
um I I had a question
um Anthony uh going back to something
you said um which I I don't know if I
completely understand you know
the statement or its implications but it
seems very interesting so you said well
look um you know in terms of the
rejection sampling you know you have to
use Marriott Waters if you're in the
discrete case but but you know once you
make it continuous it all takes care of
itself and
uh so somehow to to me I I don't I don't
really understand that statement
completely you know it seems like
getting something for nothing and um so
so what's what's going on there I mean
are you are you saying that um you know
all this Marriott virtuous you can just
get rid of totally you know and just
move to continuous time and and uh
surely there's a penalty to pay there
right uh
um um
yeah I'll try to say something in the
unjust simply more of the average like
details to it um so it seems originally
there's some proposal of doing
Metropolis using Maria watches and then
the problem encounter is that um
when your energies actually have
continuous when energy can like can
distribute continuously
how you don't know how to cut the two
like the two things like sometimes
things would just be in right in the
middle and you don't know if the energy
is like here or there and that yes you
can kind of grind through the
calculation and it just give you some
blow up in complexity
um
and I think right now we still don't
know how to make it work even borrowing
from this continuous picture
um but that's not like okay so we're
still trying to understand why this
continuous thing is so nice
and yeah
yeah I guess we are still in the process
of understanding it I was actually just
thinking about this like How Deeply
relates to each other like this
continuous response today and uh so
there is something xeno-like effect
going on here we actually have an
implementation of this lean bloody
evolution by a weak measurement and then
it's very reminiscent so one way of
doing this is kind of just going in hard
to do the jump and then try to go back
and then it's difficult and then what we
do in this weak measurement Gadget
instead is do the jump but except the
jump only with a tiny probability even
if it was a success Puja and then
uncompute and it turns out that while
you make some kind of better strong jump
you only make a data Square uh issue in
in in reverting so it's a bit like a
Quantum Xeno effect so if you only like
measure weekly then then going back you
only make kind of a triviality version
of the measurement only makes a tinier
and then just scale down that and then
this is how it happens and then and then
you can understand this uh like lean
blood operation as just a limit of this
of this weekend we can measurement to
repeat it for longer longer times
mm-hmm okay
so address does it relate to your
Quantum luas local Lemma algorithm or
its different
uh I was also thinking about this today
during lunch and
it's a bit different uh
somehow in that case you need to modify
the accept branch and then that's the
issue and here kind of the issue is
doing the rejection
some somehow
it's a bit different uh like certainly
there is a relation but but it's it's
also has some fundamental differences
well and just just like one small
comment on this that topic you would
have some very interesting paper coming
out last week
and and it also uses uh some kind of
weak measurement like ideas to to handle
this non-committing hematonians
Grand set preparation and so it's
interesting how this week measurements
pop up in all these non-computive
settings and give you something so maybe
there is a more like fundamental
connection between them but if that's
still to be like understand better
understand better
foreign
I did have one uh so so my my initial
response was about polynomial time
algorithms and and the optimism for that
uh but I I also have a kind of comment
Anthony about the um the kind of like uh
I mean I think you fit the uh
the the mysteries of low energy states
and the kind of uh you know in your
picture you had this kind of like worst
case qma hard and you know that's bad
and then and then over here we have uh
polynomial time algorithms and that's
good and of course you don't disagree
with that but um
I think there is also a mystery above
and beyond qma hardness for these Gibb
States
um because you know yes it's qma hard
but uh what is the complexity of of
preparing the Gibb State and Computing
expected values with respect to I mean
this is something we
um we asked in our in our paper from
last year but certainly did not resolve
and I think you know for example many
physicists have been interested in the
question
you know in in relation to certain
questions about black holes I think uh
the question of can you design a local
hamiltonian whose ground state is the
purified Gibb State and you know that's
really a complexity Theory question like
is is preparing Gibb states of the same
complexity as the local hamiltonian
problem I mean roughly speaking and you
know is qma the worst it can get and uh
so my uh my uh
yeah my comment is just that uh I think
there's even more mystery than uh
than uh than maybe was on the slide
one thing I can add like regarding
preparing purified gift States algorithm
um you can I mean I guess the standard
colonization scheme is
you can purify it
um to get
I guess this Markov chain Dynamic itself
is nice then the purify Keepsake is also
easy
but it's it would but then it would the
then it will be the ground state of this
the guardian so it's like some horrible
operator it's not really like a local
government
hmm
yeah so I think I think the best upper
bound we have for like Computing
expected values in a Gibb State I mean
is is sort of sharp P like you know it's
I think
uh it's sharp p and I don't think we
have a better upper bound on the
complexity of that
that quantity
uh sharp B uh I like
you I see so so we showed in our paper
that additively approximating
how the expected value is in a Gibbs
state
is as hard as relative error
approximation of the partition function
and you know that's as hard as counting
the number of witnesses of a qma
verifier to some relative error and you
know those problems are all in some
class that is of unknown complexity
between qma and Sharpie
um
but uh so I you know I I guess I also
kind of Wonder Anthony like to what
extent your your you know these new
results about uh you know limbodians and
so on can address these sorts of
complexity Theory questions that are
even not even about efficient
computation but just about the place of
thermalization uh amongst the other
problems we know that are hard like the
local auditoring problem and so on
yeah I think that would definitely
require a better understanding of the
mixing time
um and how I guess how that differs from
from a classical case I mean people seem
to have studied spin glass for a long
time and they have all these nice
classical picture of like a local
minimum Etc kind of connected to
complexity but yeah right now I don't
know how those picture would change in a
Content picture
um because it seems like you want to go
to energy bases but you still care about
local operators so I don't know how they
interplay
um
or how these local minimum kind of
manifests itself in these algorithms so
sometimes I wouldn't get stuck in some
way whenever some condition happens like
we have lots of content or computer but
I have no idea what those should look
like
yeah I guess I guess I'm just making a
slightly different point because it's
true that it's it's hard to find the low
energy states of a spin glass
um but you know Computing the partition
function or thermal averages is not much
harder than that because by stockmair
it's in the third level of the
polynomial hierarchy and BPP with an
oracle for NP so so the partition
function problem for classical systems
is is sort of understood because it's NP
hard and not much harder than NP it's in
this third level of the pulling that we
have hierarchy to compute a relative
error estimated partition function
whereas for Quantum systems uh you know
that that question and the question of
additively approximated meaning thermal
uh expected values like if you had the
Gibb State Computing the expected value
we don't know the complexity of that of
those problems okay so so sorry uh David
I'm not sure I understand are you saying
uh these methods might help you
show hardness or or that or that you're
thinking it might be easy
oh no I I mean these Pro so certainly
Computing in the worst case as Anthony
said you know these these they're in the
worst case these problems are q a hard
so for example computing expected values
of a poly operator in the Gibb state is
a hard problem but you know I'm
interested in what is exactly the
hardness of that problem is it more like
qma or more like sharp p
and so you know
any kind of new understanding of how we
can prepare Gibbs States or you know I
was also interested in for example this
um brandow and other others paper on um
Quantum imaginary time Evolution which
which had seemed to say some interesting
things about dupe State preparation uh
you know so so anytime I hear about new
developments in this area I kind of
wonder what extent they can be deployed
not just for efficient algorithms but
also for our understanding of the worst
case complexity of these problems
um though so lots of questions oh sorry
yeah so if a is a local operator uh is
it no whether it can or cannot satisfy
eth
there are a lot of numerics
yeah that's
I believe it says ith in a certain
models
I think yeah I think people do it I
think even you can take lots of them and
they're all Simpson says like ath
let the precise condition is very hard
because like it's very hard to check if
something is a random Matrix it can only
do some tests
but then all these tests agree with from
The Matrix
is it clear how wide the width depend on
the choice of the poly
um so you can definitely bounce because
like you know the local poly doesn't
change energy by too much so you can
basically restrict it to a small window
but even but below that it's not very
clear
um
yeah it just required like diagonalizing
the Matrix saying can do like tiny spins
15 times
um any any final thoughts um
I had a quick I had a question uh but I
don't know uh does someone else want to
share something before I want to I mean
maybe I'll just try so so
um
um your second part of the result says
that assuming ath uh
this um this Quantum Marco chain
converges fast but we know that there
are some complexity Theory reasons for
certain give states to be hard to
prepare
so does your result give a complexity
theoretic refutation of EDH in some
systems uh you know like I guess there's
a big open question out there
or things like that it's widely debated
but it seems like you're coming with a
different angle here that look here's a
complete the reason why its should not
hold in many systems out there
yeah I mean I think that the seller
definitely sounds plausible I mean like
um I think this depends on how you want
to set out the problem like if you do
you want to so I guess if you only
certified something it's definitely not
eth
um then it's kind of related like how do
you check a gap of expander kind of
questions
um
that's I don't think that's always easy
I mean it depends on what yeah sometimes
it's checking things that is quite hard
um
especially I guess contact I think
there's some existing work that trading
checking content expanded Gap is really
isn't qma hard if I remember correctly
uh right now so what I was asking I
guess is in terms of exhibiting
exhibiting local Hamilton systems which
violate ADH I mean
my understanding is that somehow people
don't believe anymore that many body
localization is you real because it's
not stable under perturbations
uh but again physicists should correct
me if I'm wrong I'm but this is this is
my uh picking up things from having
lunch with people
it's so so uh if EDS is always the
stable point of everything then does it
mean that complexity theoretic hardness
is not stable you know I mean there are
all sorts of questions you can ask and I
was wondering at what level they've
already been answered by your work so
let me now put on a physicist hats uh
um so what's expected is that I think
most system at high temperature are
pretty much chaotic unless you make them
very integrable
um but integrable you can perturb it
maybe breaks maybe this quasi integrable
maybe but then most likely lots of
things are just very clear I think at
high temperature uh and then and low
temperature very much becomes more
solvable in some way like if a gap
system that you might have this particle
picture that you have some expectations
like one particularly particle
um that's not quite eth
um
um and or if you have a
spin class system or just more exotic
but then it would might just becomes a
very hard combinatorial problem kind of
below a certain temperature
[Music]
um
yeah so I think there are definitely
things to be young eth
um
[Music]
and I would believe that if you try to
put like some complexity some very high
complexity State you shouldn't mix
Ed
thanks great um
I have like another comment or question
that is like going in a different
direction
than all these questions so can you re
your first result on you know sampling
uh tell you anything you know it's a
long shot like tell you anything on
classification of phases because you
have essentially a result that you know
holds for different values of beta even
going to go into the wrong state right
and you know there's a
whole field of people trying to well
first of all if you just focus on close
systems there's a bunch of people that
have been working on classification
faces for a while there and there's not
a clear agreement on the definition of
how to define different phases for open
systems and how to classify them so
there are many different attempts in the
last few years in the literature and
some of them have to do just with dkf
correlation so
gives states of ground organic states of
hamiltonians some others have to do with
different values for the mixing time and
I don't know if the you know the the
brain what the bound that you're
obtaining for the sampling in your
result could give you some information
there and I think this is kind of
related to the question of how tight is
study estimation
so because you have an estimation there
so do you know if it's tight for certain
values of beta and for some other values
of beta it breaks and then you have like
a some form of phase transition there or
something like that
yes so for classified basis um
I have this thing about it
um I've definitely heard people talking
about like how um
um
yeah
let me let me think about it later
um but for for the second part
um
um so right now the most mysterious
thing that I could have created that
probably encode all the interesting
physics systems
all the other parameters are just very
simple just like linear dependence and
like inverse one over Epsilon
um I don't think those encodes too much
of physics
um but this mixing time is really
mysterious
um
and definitely you can imagine this
mixing time will start diverging if
maybe like if you get very close to
Southern temperature
and then something else happens but
that's actually at least definitely one
thing that could happen and you can tell
very like you can see very clearly
um
[Music]
okay thanks yeah so sorry but but just
to go ahead with that so so the mixing
time has to do with these jumps which
which don't come from the hamiltonian
right so it's something that you're
picking separately so how intrinsic is
it to the physical system
yes
um
is that clear um practically I guess if
you have poly XYZ locally that it should
work
um but maybe sometimes you have to do
something more fancy like you have like
flip two things at the same time in a
very distant location maybe that will
help but I don't know like I think yeah
it largely depends on the system
um
yeah but if you just have a few like few
a few body operators that's like there
are not too many of them so you might as
well just throw all of them in
and I guess the algorithm doesn't depend
so much on the number of jumps you want
to use it's like log a not log number of
things because
great
um anybody else um
I I could ask one more but I don't know
how much time is allotted uh no it's
fine it's fine we we can we can have one
more question okay well well I I was you
know following up on anarch's earlier
question about the um like refuting eth
V you know uh for for certain systems
where where you know you shouldn't be
able to wear the ground state or thermal
State
um it seems to me like probably
physicists would not tell you that eth
is exactly satisfied in any system right
you know and uh probably there's some
natural notion of approximate eth uh and
I wonder to what you know how delicate
is you are uh is your convergence proof
I mean if you if you take the natural
notion of approximate dth whatever that
may be first of all do you know what it
is and second of all do you think uh
your proof uh adapts well to the
approximate version yeah I think this is
these prove our
these people are robust but that's also
why it's very nasty because these depend
on some like
um
but it's very robust
um and these expand their properties
um
right so so answer to a question is that
okay what is this quantity like weak eth
you can really think of it as some kind
of
like expander gap of a bunch of across
operators
um or it's a gap so a little bit
definitely stable
if you don't put every too much
um and um
so that's one kinetic quality and I'm
sure it's pretty robust um you can even
prove that for generic group and a
matrices it always have the gap
um and
further like if you say a lot would be a
sensible definition of eth without
directly going without exactly
addressing individual energies
um definitely I think using you can use
some low low moment approximation with
quantities you wanted
um because Capricorn is roughly to
access the Gap you roughly just need
like a degree load the polynomial
yeah and yeah so definitely many low
moment things could capture ethn already
thanks very much so well uh thanks
Anthony for a great talk and thank you
Angela
[Music]
andras and David for
yeah great panel
so
um so you know next week we uh we we
won't have the colloquium uh it's both
the fox deadline but also for people
with kids it's spring break so we'll
we'll skip next week and
and we'll resume again the week after
so see you then and thank you everybody
thanks
thank you bye bye